[Music]
a british man has paid up to 300 000
since 2014
in plastic surgery to make himself look
like a korean woman no this guy's gonna
look
this guy's gonna look dope so there was
that one dude that wanted to be a k-pop
guy that's the same guy oh wait now it's
a korean woman yup yo is there a guy
getting all this the same dude he was
trying to look like jimin from [ __ ]
bts yeah now it's like so he wanted to
look like a korean man he was trying to
look like
a korean pop star
but he gave up on one guy in bts yeah a
specific guy and then he gave up on that
and now like all of them is now
switching to just looking like a woman
he was trying to say that he he
identifies as being
i mean that looks nothing like a korean
girl
the guy's white that just looks like a
las vegas like a retired las vegas
[ __ ] stripper
michael jackson knows though yeah that
triangle knows
what did she look like that [ __ ] that's
a [ __ ] street performer at [ __ ]
fremont street right there
[ __ ] fremont street she's a cocktail
waitress dude got a lego set on his face
let me find the before ben you got to go
so far back for these before well i
think um when when it was uh when when
at the when at the time he was trying to
be a k-pop or identify as korean
or he spent hundreds of thousands
already
that's the before before whoa
is that ucla dude
[Laughter]
so he was trans-racial now he's
transgender racial transgender
trans-racial gender
he said that he doesn't he doesn't yet
identify as a woman but he might in the
future but he sure does identify as a
korean
uh trans racially yeah i believe so
trans racial gender potential right now
he identified as like can we talk about
trans racial for a second yeah we'll
start there did he wait did he get a did
he want to get a penis reduction too so
he could be more korean and [ __ ] that's
crazy that's a slap in my face dude
that's just like in my face
no just the uh the penis thing
i don't know what stereotypes you heard
i heard but that's definitely not true i
heard singapore i heard that on the
flight there in the [ __ ]
the people
that singapore airlines says the people
singaporeans are big dongs
we're flying out at 24 hours
2000 feet singaporean dick's currently
at eight inches
average yes
welcome on board to singapore airlines
live where we have big
yeah dude
but that's your way of you're like
playing the opposite to make a surprise
when we finally see your dick huh no
definitely not
definitely i wish i wish that was just
setting the bar low so that when he
shows his average dick we go whoa that's
a big [ __ ] dick bro three inches is
that three inches really
i like we got to go to a cream spa
together oh my god let's do it wait but
that's like
a lot of [ __ ] money dude three
hundred grand a ton of money that's a
house dog yeah what does it do for a
living that's crazy but why did he want
to be a korean pop star so bad for clout
is that what it was
well so like this person ali london is
his name and he's a really big
personality on social media and has
admitted to just being addicted to like
you know content and algorithm and just
constantly creating and you know oh so
this is the factor it's all about it's
almost like
the worst thing that could probably
happen to ollie london is probably to be
done having surgery because there's
nothing
oh so he just needs to keep that's my
personal opinion what do you think his
new thing is after this british i think
he got more addicted to having
development i was about to say this is
probably his hobby dude it's like when
you add new parts to your car
yeah she's just like i'm gonna get a
wide body kit you know
a lot of new skin is what it is exactly
yeah i'm gonna get a front lift because
part of it too for this guy is like i
wonder how far i could push it that was
developing a [ __ ] fortnite character
right
i mean
it's funny because this this is a quote
from him he said i have quite an
obsessive and impulsive personality i
discovered beautiful korean women on
tick tock and decided i want to look
like them and then he finds out later
they're chinese he went for it yeah he
did it i mean i appreciate how
straightforward he is about like what
he's doing he's like yeah i like the way
they look i want to look like that that
kind of makes me feel okay with it bro i
bet when he gets allergies that [ __ ] is
crazy but it's like but it's like when
he sneezes that must be a mess just oh
like a bunch of silicone no it's just
stuck in there
oh yeah what do you think the quality of
life is when you get so much plastic
surgery over a period of time like that
i mean if that's your [ __ ] thing he
probably loves it no matter how it feels
you think it's good when you're fighting
with plastic surgery
it just gets crunchy it's knocked off
yeah you're just like uh that doesn't
hurt
yeah
he says i am obsessed with tick tock and
i feel like i need to look more
beautiful to get more brand deals so
from a business perspective it makes
sense for me to continue going under the
knife that's what a lot of girls say too
like they just get
like minor plastic surgeries like oh
it's an investment it's a slippery slope
like a lot of them will start with the
deviated septum surgery and they'll go
oh since i'm in there might as well make
my nose better and then it just goes
well i can do this i need to get that
surgery i think there's some girls
though where you see their before and
after and i'm like
good for you
but what if they have kids and then the
kids look nothing like them yeah that's
what i'm worried about like like kylie
jenner you have the kid's surgery there
yo did you see that picture of the of
that rich i don't know if they're korean
or chinese
yeah yeah and all the babies came out
[ __ ] ugly as [ __ ] did you see how
that how that wasn't true and it ruined
that woman's life no
that's [ __ ] up
yeah that that meme or whatever was
explaining like was a like a
a whole like fraud thing would it never
happened
there was like a picture like a like a
couple no yeah but i was like what's the
real story behind that there is no real
story
they just like photoshopped it or
something oh really the babies were
photoshopped i don't know which
one like it ruined her life so they're
all cute babies and they could have
photoshopped them or the mom would could
have been ugly and she photoshopped her
like just something was photoshopped
yeah something was changed to make the
joke make sense and then um
and then it like that was a good joke
went around and like i think she like
some [ __ ] happened where she couldn't
work at her place anymore and then wow
she was gonna kill herself and she got
real serious there's some influencer
girls though where like you know how
like haters dig up their old photos and
[ __ ] and then like whatever and i've
seen the before and after and i'm like
i'm pretty sure that they wouldn't have
their millions of followers and like all
these brand deals and whatever if they
stayed the way that they looked because
it's it's the whole their whole business
is based on what they look like right
it's not their personality literally
everyone like ariana grande uh kendall
jenner cardi b like if you look just
like 10 years ago oh yeah everyone gets
work done like a little bit just little
tiny adjustments and you don't you don't
notice it over time but then when you
see old pictures that pop up you're like
whoa that was crazy
i saw a old picture of scissor you know
sizzle
and she looked way different from like
that was like circulating around tick
tock where from what she looks like now
when like what you were saying when she
looked like when like five years ago
what's some of the distinct features of
her nose like you could tell her nose is
like distinctly different yeah now she
got like it's like way smaller and it's
like more of like a button nose more
like a oh
i wish they did like different styles
though because that everyone just looks
like kim kardashian or they just want
the [ __ ] big cheek that's everyone in
l.a huh like why are you doing it the
same way
like can somebody do like a big job
it's like when you create a wrestler in
those old [ __ ]
like why can't someone just have
frankenstein bolts in their side of
their head
can i can i have a neanderthal look like
can i get low cheekbones like come on
like i want to see i want to see
different styles yeah yeah yeah i was
like it's all the same nobody has the
ingenuity to do it nah dude everyone
just wants to look the same it's almost
like it's own sport like they're not
doing it anymore for the approval of
like you or me it's like it's almost
like they're just racing each other
yeah i want to get like the buddha ears
so i look wise
i mean you can make more money i say you
gotta take it as fact you just throw
them around all the time well actually
did i ever show you this yeah you do
they [ __ ] stretch this far look whoa
[ __ ] you do have buddha they stretched
that far yeah bro i believe everything
you say in it what are they what are
those very wise
um because when i was a kid i had a
habit of just pulling on them all the
time oh so you stretch though yeah so i
just inadvertently stretch them the way
that like when you get plugs
so they like they used to go what did
you do as a kid walk around life like
this i used to just sit in the car and
just go
my dad would just look at me like the
[ __ ] wrong with you get your ears
pierced no that's why a lot of people
think i used to have plugs because this
is how it looks like when you used to
have that's what i assumed wow
you had plugs i should be right in the
ear
you got a [ __ ] chihuahua skin here
dude you have a nut sack earlobe bro
have you guys considered getting work
done like any plastic surgery any of
that enhancing anthony wanted his face
done
all right his whole face no he did it
we pressured him into thinking that dude
do braces count that's pretty costly i
had braces too i need to get him again
oh shit's [ __ ] but you know what's
funny is everyone who's had braces got
it at the advice of their parents like
it's not like i was like oh my teeth are
[ __ ] but oh i gotta i i got it when i
did it yourself i got it no not myself
i went to orthodontics
no uh my mom's insurance oh [ __ ] i would
i would do a rare one though like
low-key i would like extend my fingers
just a little bit
just just like just like that much
just like long fingers low-key do rare
ones and see if people pick up on it
like oh they go it's a little bit longer
like i'll do this and everyone's just
like
i'd have a [ __ ] sword on my elbow dog
what
like a cartoon
fingernail in my elbow oh yeah yeah
if a plastic surgeon went hey i'll do it
for free as long as it's weird what
would you get i would get like a like a
shark fin of mine oh a shark fin that's
tight the back of my neck yeah like this
so when you move your hair like this
you're like wow and then there's like a
little shark i'm swimming there's just a
little like what the hell
it's like
[Laughter]
yeah i'd probably get some rare ones i
want hordes
oh like that that's like yeah mind style
horns right here you want there you
[ __ ] devil you actually would get
horns i would
because you know that's not that's not
even that expensive judges him hard he's
like oh i want it on the side
like another finger here so you can like
hold your phone like this you know like
all words you know you know you put your
pinky
i would just get another finger do we
cover the jk story
it was a it was a holder and it was like
an attachment you put on your hand and
the bottom part was like another finger
yeah i would just get one yeah
like right there i could just hold my
phone and go on my phone see guys are
trying to think of functional [ __ ] not
me i want i want my butthole to be a
[ __ ]
why
just soak up both that looks tight
you just said you would switch it out so
you're not both yeah no my butt my
butthole is a [ __ ] you want it to act
like a functional useless right now
anyways oh so you just want a labia on
outside if you have a labia and a cl you
want a clitoris
so if i spread my butt cheeks then you
see a [ __ ] in a bunch of yoshinoya on
the outside is that what you're doing
that'll be tight you should know your
body yeah
a little arby's
you're gonna have to wipe so much
arby's rb roast beef
oh
is that what that means i don't know i
think so maybe
whoa
whoa
or is it someone's name
i don't know aren't mr rb you're good
the lobes have spoken
[Music]
uh
[Music]